[موسيقى]
حبيت ارسم قبل ما ادخل المدرسه في ذيك
الايام كان في اهتمام غير عادي للثقافه من
ضمنهم الفن التشكيلي
اول معرض في حياتي شاركتي
الصف الرابع ابتدائي كان هناك في تحول غير
عادي لما دخلت مرسم الحر وشفت كتب
الفنانين الكبار كان السوق الخاص قلت ركز
على
انك كنت مغرم بفنان رمران
[موسيقى]
في 67 بعد النكسه ستعدت لوحات لوحات
اللاجئين كوني كنت عايش في الكويت بعيدا
عن اهلي بكيت احس احاسيسهم كيف البعد عن
الوطن وعن الاهل
كان في هناك وقفه لمده 12 سنه كان يسافر
الى امريكا وشاهدتي للمناظر
الطبيعيه اللي كانت موجوده هناك اجبرتني
اشتري ادوات الرسم وبديت حقيقه وانا
بالطياره في وقت الى البلاد
التسعينات دخلت عالم التجريد كانت كتحدي
ولكن حقيقه شفت يعني في الحريه في 92 دخلت
الاحرف العربيه في لوحات ايش اسمها اعطي
للوحه صبغه عربيه
من الاشياء المهمه في حياتي لوحه تعتبر
تاريخ دبي موجوده على المترو عباره عن 22
قطعه في حدود متر ونصف في 40 متر ايضا
ركزت على المواضيع التراثيه فيما بعد مزجت
بين التجريد والانطباعيه اشتهرت باستخدام
المربعات في اعمالي
[موسيقى]
مع الحب
والتصميم على الاتقان ممكن الانسان يصل
الى اعلى المراتب
[موسيقى]